so the question that I was asked this
time was now I was going to answer this
straight with examples like lost
campesinos romances boring wide mouth
mason self-titled album Holly McMullen
stuff new radicals maybe you've been
brainwashed to the watchman's silent
radar Hawksley workman last night we
were the delicious wolves albums that a
lot of the audience probably hasn't
heard of because either they're regional
or fairly underground or just didn't get
a lot of traction on their own and so I
thought about it but then I said no
that's too easy
we're gonna do this hard mode so instead
we're going to try and defend the
indefensible regret albums a second look
first up three doors down the better
life all right well let's just get let's
just get headphones on and then and then
we're gonna take it and we're gonna put
it yeah whatever Bowie magic doesn't
matter it's not like I'm gonna stand
here and actually listen to it anyway
alright this album sucks for the most
part now it's not the worst and I mean
kryptonite from a songwriting
perspective something as strong with a
hook as kryptonite that's you know
that's commendable
but it's pretty it's it's forgettable
yeah they did yeah yeah up next jewel
spirit
I've already forgotten this album and I
just finished listening to it alright
next is Marcy Playground shapeshifter
okay so this album super weird but not
in a particularly good way it's kind of
campy and yeah yeah all right what's
what's next
Evanescence fallen 14 year old you loved
this album it's a good thing 14 year old
you isn't around anymore and last on the
list is Creed my own prison
Scott staffs more like Scott
so it turns out that every single one of
these has been largely forgotten for
good reason so that was a horrible
experiment and we'll probably never do
it again
like share subscribe